you
hi everyone it's Jerry I'm on Lee chess
and I'm playing a Fischer random game
against banana dealer all right let's
see I think this is a good start I don't
want to take too much time on the first
move I know you probably should but uh
you know I want to get things kicked off
I think this is a good a good start I
like having this knight right behind the
pond and we could maybe mmm this is a
pretty awkward piece in the corner snipe
I was going to say we could maybe start
to see this evolve into like a bird's
opening I'm wondering about Knight f3
and then g3 hmm maybe I make actually
another pawn move now b4 and then Knight
b3 although b4 gives this square up for
Knight b6 into here I'm gonna I'll have
to be a bit careful about that I think
actually this is a good start this is
this was very tempting but if I play
Knight f3 and then g3 the bishop can
make use of this square so my idea here
is g3 Bishop g2 Knight f3 so let's let's
swing the back completely around let's
follow through with that I'm wondering
if maybe there was some quick way to
open up the position because this is a
pretty slow approach that I took here to
organize the pieces yeah so let's just
go here so now when I castle the king
I'll just go over to g1 in the rook I'll
stay let's see yeah as mentioned I'm I
have to be a bit hesitant with this b4
move excuse me this seems to run in 294
possibilities I think I want to do this
move
um and there's no rush let's let's do
the move that I know I'm gonna have to
make anyhow let's do that right away so
yeah I'm thinking d3 what's this Queen
up to okay I guess they're trying to
eliminate my light-square bishop uh-huh
okay well I don't think there's much I
could do about that anyhow let's let's
get this move in here um you know what
wait a second
maybe maybe I do go with v4 what am I
talking about v4 doesn't make this a
whole I was silly my pond will be fine
here or well it I'm still afraid of
night 2 a 4 a 4 would be seriously
weakened after a b4 move if I play
Knight B 3 C 5 how about I go B 3 C 5
and then Bishop b2 Knight c2
hmm decision time I'm gonna I'm gonna
gun for this if the night wants to go to
a four I'm gonna let him go to a 496
Bishop b2 knight a four Bishop e5 and
then maybe I could even step my queen up
to b3 to challenge the night we're gonna
see
um yeah given some time I want to get
this move in Bishop b2 and if it's not
quick enough night a4 I can maybe even
tuck my Bishop back in the corner
so Knight b6 okay they're striking right
away I think I know oh you know after I
take the Queen recaptures with check
uh-huh yeah I have moved my F pawn
haven't I Oh should that really be so
big a deal well I really don't want to
do that uh yeah let's let's actually hmm
this is tricky yeah this is pretty
tricky I don't like inviting the Queen
forward um yeah I'm gonna do this I
don't want to be so quick to give up the
c5 square to the Queen you know takes
I'm gonna recapture with a pawn maybe I
get Knight b3 and then look as start to
view the d4 square as a whole it's not a
whole by definition because the pond
could control it at some point but I
have this pawn here watching over it
probably this or no I should do this
move I have to give up my dark square
Bishop eventually though mm-hmm I'm in
some trouble here this Knight a form of
is gonna hurt me well yeah I'm suffering
here already hmm Knight b6 into a for
these dark squares are really hurting me
okay I'm gonna try to get by with this I
think Knight a 494 Bishop e5 takes takes
Knight c3 although no Knight a for
Bishop e5 pawn takes Queen takes before
I think I need to cover C 3 and C 2 is
defended okay we might be having this
also this is a super weakened point
III as soon as I played to this diagonal
so I move like Knight g4 could hurt me
dropping into here yeah they're going
straight for that it's gonna be painful
look at my dark squares it's hurts yeah
this is hurtin Knights gonna that
Knights gonna kill me yeah let's let's
just try to move forward look at this
guy in the corner tough day at the
office probably be five and I'm close to
resigning you know what do I do
or I do about a night that's gonna
arrive right here ah what to do hmm
I got a lash I feel like I need to lash
out so let's do that I think there's
just a winning continuation with c4 c4
and then no matter where my queen goes
the knight c3 is gonna hit with the fork
mm-hmm all right well my plan here is
gonna try to complicate things I don't
know how successful I'll be with that
but I have to I have to get it try and
make it a bit messy here as best as I
can so I'm covering this at least and
maybe I could get out of any potential
Forks by exchanging in this square first
so they went straight in for that my
Knights still in the corner and that
cool well let's go here I got to get a
new Square from it I have to get some
square for my knight I should say ah
yeah
this is real bad this diagonal is
weakened so maybe there's a timely check
I could make I don't know I should
probably kick this Knight out of here
before he hurts me or is it already too
late and now he ran away scared okay um
just uh not in a good position
that hasn't changed um throw my knight
in the center hope for the best
yeah he's got to get working though
he's got to get working no I gotta try
this I guess it's very shaky restricting
my queen like this defending the knight
yeah okay that hurts
hmm this is very difficult um yeah I
don't have much to do here my knight is
in some serious trouble alright let's go
here I could recapture with my queen I
missed that I was thinking I have to
take with the night cuz I have to watch
over this now you know they got a lot of
pressure here this night and I do
something dangerous I still have this
diagonal maybe I could make something
happen also my bishop is defended with
my knight here living off of the
increment as usual there is no be take
see because I still have pressure on the
knight see takes B I don't know if
that's really benefiting black okay
let's go here I guess yeah not sure okay
they're going for that still Undine upon
here okay yeah I feel like black could
have killed me much sooner I'm somehow
still uh fishing I think I have to try
for this hope for the best
yeah it's not much hope though yeah
that's simple and good
I guess we're gonna try for this
liquidated queenside I maybe I have
Knight g5 at some point pressure on f7
some in-betweener stuff taking here with
check I don't know are we going to have
these liquidated okay they are gone
maybe they're going to insert some
checks here I'd have to bounce back and
forth from f2 to g1 I wouldn't have
anything better that seems quite
annoying throw in another check I have
to stay out for the f1 square let's just
crawl up into a ball well so am I going
to do
I mean really um oh that hurts that's a
good move let's go here put pressure on
something it's my idea
they're going to hit with 94 I almost
lost I did those on time man yeah this
was losing anyhow but mmm yeah I would
have liked to have a little bit more I'm
not gonna spend too much attention
checking this out with the computer but
yeah I wonder you know it's always when
I play the Fisher randoms it's always
interesting to me how to you know the
the early stage how exactly to organize
the pieces and yeah this F form of um
maybe not such a good idea I mean I
really started to feel some pressure on
this dog you know you know whenever you
even even in the Fisher random games
right as soon as you touch your f on one
or two squares forward your king is
vulnerable both ranked and diagonal um
yeah and that got to be a bit annoying
because that c5 push in the Queen just
the threat of the Queen arriving here
and the e3 square my opponent did really
well to highlight these weaknesses the
weakness of the diagonal the weakness of
the the e3 square
and uh yeah I was in some serious
trouble let's click on this and see what
it uh let's actually go to huh
yeah as you're seeing down I think you
could see it yeah it's in there - three
so yeah way down hill right around what
point yeah soon as c5 hit in my reply to
c5 a three and that's where there's a
mistake and it was just downhill from
there
ah let's see hmm
it just it did just pop up this night b3
move I guess I guess I have to I don't
know then maybe that's a bit too strong
but Knight b3 hmm maybe three yeah maybe
maybe maybe my infatuation here with
having ponds out in front of my Knights
is maybe a bit of a stretch I think it's
a pretty decent general guide to go
forward with but in this particular case
trying to trying to make it happen over
here on the Queen side with a V for
Knight b3 maybe have to come up with
something else just night b3 or maybe
even c3 Knight c2
yeah I mean my opponent pounced on like
it
not every weakness but enough of them
you know I had before up what did the
knight do he jumped into a four III was
weakened what did he do he jumped or at
least threatened to go into e3 the
diagonal was weakened ordered black do
he'd tried to exchange alpha pond that
was on that square so the Queen get
there yeah that was it was a very good
game by my opponent I mean the the b4
move
oblah should shy away from the okay so I
want with Chitra I think this is still
fine what I'm doing on the kingside but
how I went forward on the queenside you
know something needs to change there now
what's coming for before okay computer
likes before all of a sudden I don't
understand chess okay I went D three
castles now Knight B three no that still
likes before I don't understand
okay I went with bee farm c5 it wants to
take this does not feel right to take
and then after the recapture what I'm in
check why are you calling out for b4
here this doesn't feel right after a
Czech night here yeah I don't know
what's going on here why is this here
I'll popping up like that all right
anyhow yeah this it just doesn't feel
right this b4 move these these squares
weakened and this Knight jumping in here
turned out to be more of a problem than
they would have anticipated I saw that
we can see three but I thought I could
remedy that I was also hmm he's he's
overloaded maybe this is another way to
view it I mean he already from c1
already maybe even back up right here as
soon as I played d3 this move right here
is placing a certain restriction on my
bishop and couple that with the move B
for now it's just tremendous a
tremendous weakening of my dark squares
and this was maybe that's that maybe
that's the big summary with this one the
dark star square weaknesses were really
exploited in this one the dark diagonal
here and these three a3 c3 III squares
we're really pounced on or threatened
you know
five a three is what it doesn't like
it's suggesting what we already looked
at it to just capture and then before
yeah I guess something's going a little
screwy there if they're calling for B
for an illegal move but uh yeah maybe
maybe B for isn't even a good idea to
begin with maybe there's something messy
going on right here but um yeah III
think I should do something different
maybe night b3 night b3 and c5 I really
didn't like this you have to do it like
this even c3 Knight c2
I don't know
it's tricky I'd even I'd even go as far
back as my first move with f4 you know
as mentioned this this idea that I'm
having with having the pawns out in
front of my Knights I'm doing that in
both cases here V for f4 and then the
Knights right behind so III kind of like
that set up because it's a harmonious
when the pawn is out in front of the
night like that he has these support
points these advancing support points
but uh yeah maybe a bit too much in this
one weakening my dark squares yeah and
it was really as you see here what the
evaluation was really just downhill but
you know really and I guess a disaster
with the opening here huh I could easily
happen with Fisher random and down upon
here I think there was something even
better for my opponent right around here
after I played efore doesn't c4 just win
on the spot because these two squares
are covered and now oh you know what I
have this capture actually I was
thinking I have to go to one of these
two and then Knight c3 hits with the
fork but I do have this capture and on V
takes I could take the night and on
detail
because I could first take here and then
well I mean it's still it's still very
difficult I mean a night getting here
look at this guy in the corner I can't
even look at him anymore
okay um I guess that's what you get
sometimes with Fisher random it's been a
while since I posted one of these to the
channel but anyhow feel free to leave
any feedback to this video I know it's
not the best ending a lot of frustrated
viewers I'm sure whenever I lose on time
my time management but yeah that's going
to happen and any holiday feel free to
leave any feedback in the comments
section below are you a fan of Fisher
random I enjoy playing it from time to
time and also the three check I'll have
to do another three check I haven't
gotten around to that in a while but
anyhow feel free to leave any feedback
in the comment section below to this
video and as usual I hope you enjoyed it
that's all for now take care bye
you